[Music]
hey guys welcome back to another video
and this video is a paid promotion for
google yeah so Google has been so
awesome they sent over in Google home
menu for us to check out this past
couple week and it's been super handy
having it in the house because we've
been able to use it to help you with
your homework yeah I can cooking and I
need to get recipes fast and bam right
there yeah so like what are some of the
questions you've been asking Google cuz
I've been hearing you play with it
around the house you can you go hey
Google oh hi there I'm ready to help
what can I do for you yeah hey Google
can you tell us a joke
what did the teacher do with their
students report on the history of cheese
she graded it like cream again like also
when you grate some cheese you break it
up in little pieces yeah
we're also going to Dallas Texas for a
holiday break so let's find out what the
weather is up in Dallas yeah yeah hey
Google what's the weather like in Dallas
Texas currently in Dallas it's 57 and
clear the forecast tonight is 73 in
clear that's actually good weather you
know recently I've been trying to learn
Cantonese and you have kind of been sort
of wanting to learn Spanish but you I've
been trying to teach you Spanish since
you were born you need other said you
never wanted to but now I see that
you're actually interested in Spanish
and you've been asking for Italian so
huh yeah hey Google can you translate a
joke in Spanish whenever I'm at another
cowboy your word
men speaking Spanish we actually tried
watching a Star Wars marathon only in
Spanish and you're actually excited for
the new movie coming out aren't you
excited I know he's been counting down
the days I keep asking like how many
days to December what just keep I
recently found out that there have this
Star Wars game on mobile home do you
want to play it yeah I know you've never
played it okay so this is what you asked
it hey Google Play Star Wars trivia
challenge sure let's get our Wars trivia
challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
question one complete the following
phrase from the opening crawl it is a
period of a dark times B Civil War or C
good versus evil
yeah that's ER be correct question 2
what character speaks the first line of
dialogue from the film a Darth Vader be
Princess Leia or Steve
c-3po a incorrect answer is c c 3 p.m.
well he's refers more Iman sets the
spice mines on which point a Tatooine be
Kessel or C Alderaan be correct which
Star Destroyer pursue princess Leia's
ship overtaxed me a avenger be detritus
or seat Devastator do you know C correct
before they board the escape pod r2d2
called c-3po a mindless one a
philosopher be scrap pile or sea
goldenrod a philosopher no correct in
early drafts of a new hope
r2d2 couldn't speak Standard English in
fact many of those reactions to his
comments remained in the film I want to
see that version of the movie with
anguish that'd be cool question 7 what
kind of ship does the rebel officer tell
Darth Vader they are off a Imperial be
Republic or sea consular I think your
feet I think it's
see correct yes GRU we know our Star
Wars crossing the skin question 10
what character said I want her a lot a
Darth Vader be grand moff tarkin or c
obi-wan Kenobi a correct a and that's
how we've been using our little home
thank you google for sending over a
Google home to us check in the
description below and click on the link
to get your own Google home all right
guys give this video a big thumbs up
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]